hey guys Pete here this will be my mr.
robot season 4 episode 7 recap and
review the episode was titled 407 proxy
authentication required and it was
written and directed by Sam S mail it
was a doozy of an episode to be sure a
big twist lots of tension and thank
goodness the end of era a few weeks ago
I learned the term bottle episode it was
mostly from complaints people had about
episode 4 when I realized the entirety
of this episode took place in two rooms
with just six actors involved I was like
hey I know what this is it's a bottle
episode only the restrictions they put
on this it really seemed to make it a
better experience so go figure right the
episode opens and we know that Elliott
and Bera are going to have a sit-down
since we last saw Elliott being stuffed
into the trunk of a car we know it's
still Christmas Day and there's a very
important dais group meeting later in
the same evening that Elliott needs to
get to we know that Darlene and Dom are
with Janice but we don't know what's
going on with that and how it's playing
out and we know that White Rose wants to
bring Elliott in for a discussion
because it's time he learns they're on
the same side Angela and Tyrell are
still dead which isn't great for Phillip
price on either account but he's on his
way to the prearranged location to meet
with Minister Jang Veera has injected
himself into this story he's taken
Elliott to Krista's apartment and
Elliott's gonna have to get through this
before he can deal with anything else
inside the apartment the action is
broken up into five acts there are
titles displayed on the screen as each
act opens and this makes it feel like
something important is going to happen
my thinking last week was that bureau
was going to trigger Elliott's third
alter to reveal himself that was feeling
pretty good as things started moving
along in the first act we had Elliott
the second brought out mr. robot but
alas I was barking up the wrong tree the
third act didn't produce another
personality that's not to say this
episode didn't have something big to
reveal but it started off as a pretty
standard hostage situation where the guy
we want to win has his back against the
wall mr. robot and Elliott mostly work
together here but mr. robots more
focused on escaping while Elliott is
more focused on keeping Christa safe
Vera talks a big game telling a story
like he's apt to do about going back to
the Dominican Republic and taking over
the island this doesn't do it for him no
and after seeing a shaman he realizes
that Manhattan is the island that he
needs to roll in one of my favorite
shots in the episode mr. robots eyes and
says settle in it looks like this is
going to be a long one as Vera takes
another hit from his meth pipe the
camera cuts to an overhead shot as he
continues to blabber on and then we move
into the other room to reveal that
Christa is tied up there the music and
her whimpering more or less grounds out
what he's saying and it's perfect
well I've been critical about beers
returned and just generally not liking
the character I can't overlook the
actors performance here he does a great
job of being a thoroughly unenjoyable
player in this game also as the episode
goes on it becomes clear why all those
things that suck about him are precisely
the right tools to do the job that needs
to be done here I think the thing that
stood out to me the most on the rewatch
is that when he told Elliott he was more
afraid of him than he was a mr. robot I
believed it and even though it didn't
make me like him it did make me
appreciate the characters development
mr. robot tries his best to defend
Elliott and get them out of the
situation he lets everyone know how
things are when peanuts tries to
threaten him with a gun he points out
just how dumb beer is planned to rule
New York is which thanks for that but
Elliott eventually has to take back over
to try to entice Vieira with all the
money he's about to steal from the Deus
group that part of the plan works but
things fall apart when Ellie tries to
shoot his captors with the gun Bobby had
found it but left it there had taken all
the bullets out and now things are
officially off the rails barrel loads
the gun and holds it to Krista's head
leaving Elliot to come up with the
reason why he should let her live he
ends up saying that he needs her she
helps him and veer a season-opening to
get what he wants he insists that Krista
and Elliot show him how he helps her and
that means doing a therapy session at
gunpoint Krista resists mr. robot tries
to shut it down but Elliot makes it
happen because he can't imagine that
bear is gonna let it go it starts out
normally with Elliot telling her about
his mom dying Veera isn't having that so
he pulls out Krista's folder and he rats
its things up they make their way to the
day
Eliott jumped out of the window that's
the story Darlene told him anyway
originally Elliott thought he had been
pushed by his father christa asked if he
remembers jumping out the window or if
that's just what darlene said she
wonders why he doesn't remember for
himself and asked if it's always like
that when he loses time he says only
when mr. robot takes over when we
established that he believes mr. robot
when mr. robot says that he exists to
protect him if that's the case then why
would mr. robot be protecting him that
day what would he be protecting him from
why did he grab the baseball bat and
swung it at Edward Alderson
why hide Darlene in the closet before
their dad came into the room why jump
out the window when faced with these
questions
Eliot makes the realization that he must
have been afraid that doesn't make sense
to him though as that was his friend why
would he be afraid of him step by step
they inch closer to the truth and the
performances here are truly award-worthy
even though I was able to put the pieces
together while watching of where we were
headed I held on to the last breath with
Eliot as he tried to fight away the
realization with pain and her voice that
echoes the pain of the situation and
what was going on what's happening in
that room Christa asks did your father
sexually molest you he replies yes as if
it's only in that exact moment that he's
understanding that that is the
unbearable truth it's a rare moment in a
TV show that's so heavily theorized
about and broken down like every detail
that a twist like this can come together
it's not that people haven't made
theories about Edward being a bad person
or the idea of Elliot being a victim of
abuse hasn't been out there but it
hasn't felt like it's been on the
collective radar in relation to the end
game and yet here we are I really didn't
see this coming and it hit me like a ton
of bricks to be honest I think it goes
without saying that it was handled well
and in a way that felt genuine the
acting by everyone involved matched the
gravity of the reveal and rami malek
really outdid himself in his portrayal
of this character touching that part of
himself that he's kept buried for all
these years
it was magnificent the episode doesn't
end there though Vera has one more part
to play as he reveals to Elliot that his
is the thing that makes him important he
tells Elliot that he was molested as a
child as well and tells him he can find
an untapped source of strength in what's
happened once you've weathered a storm
like yours he says you become the storm
you hear me you are the storm and it's
the rest of the world that needs to run
for cover the interaction between Elliot
and Vera has its own merits but it's
really just the setup for Vera's end
just as it's looking like Fernando is
getting what he wanted to be the one to
bring Elliot back up after he's been
broken down Krista plunges a knife into
his back killing him in how it shot it
almost works as a twist in of itself in
that only after it happens we realized
that Elliot must have seen her coming
and that more than engaging with what
Barrow was saying he was just trying to
keep him from noticing she was there he
falls to the ground the lights go out
symbolically one by one and the five act
play comes to an end
it's a gripping hour of television that
takes all the boxes of greatness as a
standalone piece of art the acting the
soundtrack and the camerawork are all
turned up to 11 the music is so good it
even elevates Vera's monologuing at
times in a way that I wouldn't have
thought was possible it also answers one
major question that we've had for a long
time what happened that day with the
window did Edward push Elliot or did he
jump now we know mr. robot took over and
that he did in fact jump but the
horrible things his father did actually
play a part in pushing him out that
window it's crazy because this is an
answer that asks a lot more questions
and it's coming to us late in the game
as much as I love this episode on its
own I have to wonder how it relates to
this story coming to a close part of the
reason Elliot went after Ecore was to
avenge his father's death and now we're
left wondering how much of that was even
real the mr. robot alter who he created
for protection also looks like his
father so what will that mean for their
relationship going ahead I mean for what
it's worth mr. robot isn't his father in
fact he's the father he never had which
is clear after the reveal but the way
things were left and at least felt like
robot couldn't protect him anymore so
what will that actually mean the truth
is based on the fact that season 4 is
half way over at this point we just
don't know
it's daring which I like but it's also a
little scary which I don't like my hope
is that it all makes sense when seen as
a whole and my faith really hasn't been
shook here because I have been enjoying
each episode as they come I wasn't
excited about Vera returning and that
turned out swimmingly so there's no need
to worry right I mean historically I've
enjoyed the risks that mr. robot has
taken maybe more than some people so I
really do find that a lot more exciting
than I do worrying but I mean there's a
lot of balls in the air and the season
opened with only eight more days for
Elliot to live and we don't seem to be
getting to the part where we figure out
what it's all about like I said I'd like
that they're taking chances and they're
making some really great episodes and I
just hope that it all works out to
combine into something that will really
give us a memorable ending I'm really
interested to see what you guys think -
let me know in the comments about what
you think about Episode seven by itself
and season four as a whole how do we
think this reveal changes things that
we've taken for granted for so long at
this point in the story I don't think
we've seen the last of mr. robot because
Elliot would need him now more than ever
at the same time it's hard to not see
him as Edward Alderson and to rewrite
all those good dad memories we've
associated with him and what about the
other how does the third alter fit into
the mix now that things have been turned
on their heads with number one and
number two also how to start lean fit
into all of this I tend to think that
she didn't know about what happened to
Elliot but I really don't know if that's
just because that's what I want to be
true I would have to go back and
re-watch the whole thing to get a better
idea of how they interacted if Edward
abused Elliot then we have to wonder
about Darlene and even Angela for that
matter it's a lot to process and I think
that I'm just gonna leave it there let
me know what you think in the comments
please like this video if you enjoyed it
and subscribe to my channel if you
haven't already we're officially halfway
through the final season of mr. robot
thanks for watching I'll talk to you
soon